we've done a lot in the state
treasurer's office which I'm in
currently on ESG but some of the other
big ones is China's something that we're
going to have to contend with as a
country and moving forward
I mean the idea that we're still making
Pharmaceuticals over there I think is
hugely problematic they're going to be
one of the biggest uh one of the biggest
threats I think in the near and
long-term future for us but domestically
where I'm focused and I run what's
called The Hope Scholarship here in West
Virginia it's an educational savings
account we must and underline this we
must eliminate the Department of
Education it has to go wow it has to go
big Proclamation right there no the
Department of Education must be
eliminated if you look at when Jimmy
Carter put instituted that to where we
are now we used to be number one in
education in the world and where we are
now
it is not working yeah and so we need to
move that money back to the States